const verse let verse VAR these are all
ways to define variables in javascript
constant let were introduced in es6 but
var has been with us since the beginning
let's go over their differences Const is
for values that never change for
instance if I have a cost ty and I said
equal to three point one four and then
if I want to set pi again until to one
well let me run this if you look over on
the side on the console you'll see
uncaught type error assignment two
constant variable so I can't assign a
constant to a concert variable hope if I
clear my console and then I changed this
Const to a var and then I run it again
no error just to prove that was running
it will add a console log and you should
see a one show up in the console now
let's go over let let is for block level
variables so for example if I have a for
loop and then for loops are always in
blocks blocks are anything with these um
curly braces so let variables you can
see I assigned a let variable in the for
loop and I am going to a console that
log that that let there that variable
that's defined with let and as you see
if I run this it's gonna say 0 1 2 so
it's locking that the variable I styles
will let now if I try to console that
log that variable before the for loop
and then we try running this you can see
there's gonna be an error same if I take
this if I copy this and then put it
after the for loop and we would run this
again let me clear the console I'm gonna
run this again and you'll see that
there's another error so when you define
something with a let it's only available
within the block that's defined so we
are now gonna go over to var and you'll
see how it's different
Varis we're variables available to the
entire function or if it's not within a
function to the entire program I'm
actually just gonna copy this whole
thing and paste it down here
I am doing this with an encode pin but I
set the keys to be similar to sublime
text so if I just double click this I
have press control D and so I'll select
each eye and then I'm gonna press J to
switch them all to J now this let I'm
going to switch to var because we're
gonna define the variable J with var
instead of let now what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to comment out this consult
that log and let we're going to run this
and as you can see even though this
console dot log is below the for loop
it's still able to log it now if I take
this Conn stopped its console down log
and put one before the floor loop the
other one is after the for loop so if I
put this one before the for loop and run
this again you'll see in the console
undefined remember before if I assign
with let it set error now it's showing
undefined that means it knows the
variable exists because when you define
something with var it will be available
even before the time that you assigned
it so it knows it's exist but it hasn't
been assigned yet so it's showing
undefined because J does exist but it
just hasn't been defined to any number
yet so those are basically the
differences between Const var and let
and in future videos I maybe go into
even more detail well thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good